break out the colored pencils so you can
send all your friends a postcard in'
because loot is back use this pin press
storage device to create your own shaped
shelves or just make a huge shelf shape
like yourself where you can store all of
your gold-plated toilet paper if you
can't afford that type of bathroom bling
get some colored toilet paper that comes
in blue fuchsia lime green orange red
and black keep yourself busy with some
kinetic sand that you could shape and
squeeze without losing a grain because
of a secret binding agent that keeps the
granules together after playing in the
sand throw your clothes into the washing
machine laundry hamper and take a bath
with your loved one and this yin-yang
bath tub equipped with bubble massage
and a rainbow of colored lights to
choose from if that's not enough tub
entertainment and this underwater disco
ball for the ultimate bathtub party and
pull out your inflatable couch bed that
you set conveniently next to your dog's
Murphy wall bed for a little more
privacy just put on these sleep which
are headphones nestled inside a cozy
headband which you can connect to an
audio jack or any Bluetooth enabled
device for the ultimate sleeping
experience sleep inside a bear shaped
sleeping bag and strap on your squirrel
wingsuit so you can jump off cliffs and
soar squirrel is a company created by
base jumpers who strive to make suits
that give the user the ability to base
jump safely and efficiently you may be
dreaming of being a flying squirrel
because you're using this lucid dream
inducer Lucy is an advanced lucid dream
inducer that uses brain waves to detect
REM sleep and uses the vocal alert this
is a dream
take control so you can then start
controlling your dreams now wake up and
use this giant giraffe coffee cup or
just have some coffee like a Norseman in
this Viking horn test your cake without
ruining it with this cake pan that makes
a mini cake to sample on the side when
it's ready you can serve it on these I
ate some pie plates and do some heavy
lifting with these construction plate
utensils
have your dessert and drink it - with
these cocktail jellies that come in
mojito and Singapore sling set your
drink down on these glowing radioactive
element coasters that come in Radium
plutonium uranium and thorium or just
drink them like a pro with this golf
club drink dispenser speaking of woods
check out these neighbor woods clever
art pieces created by amy spitzer by
laser engraving your favorite
neighborhood into cedar like Brooklyn
Atlanta Chicago and New Orleans for
going out on the town instead just put
on your Ryan Gosling earrings and your
Hello Kitty contact lenses but don't
forget this iPhone case that comes
equipped with pepper spray so you can
protect yourself that way or by dropping
an f-bomb paperweight
that sounds dangerous so stay inside and
build this DIY arcade cabinet the port
of Pi is for the Raspberry Pi and comes
with all the parts you need and
instructions on how to construct your
own or use this touch board to transform
touch into sound it's a tool to make
your projects interactive responsive
smart and fun and can turn almost any
surface or material into a sensor like
this wall which was turned into a
talking alphabet finally light your
projects with this inflatable light bag
or melt this cat into a skeleton and as
always thanks for watching
again juvy
you